Il y a 400000 ans,
un nouvel homme voit le jour.
Il est le premier représentant
d'une famille extraordinaire :
celle des Homo Sapiens.
La nôtre.
Ses enfants traversent
|es mers et |es montagnes,
s'adaptent aux climats.
Plusieurs fois, ils perdent tout
et trouvent le moyen de survivre
et d'aller au-delà de leurs limites.
Ils apprivoisent
les plantes, les animaux.
Ils construisent des villages
et changent les paysages.
L'homme devient la plus puissante
créature du monde animal.
Ils se lancent
a |a conquête de l'imaginaire,
découvrent l'art,
la magie et les rêves.
Nous sommes leurs enfants.
Leur savoir s'est transmis
sur 50 000 générations
pour arriver jusqu'à nous.
Quelle est leur véritable histoire ?
Comment ont-ils peuplé la terre ?
Comment ont-ils fait
pour que nous soyons là aujourd'hui?
Voici l'histoire de la fabuleuse
ascension de notre grande famille,
celle des Homo Sapiens.
Thème musical
Comment débute cette histoire ?
Comment notre espèce
est-elle apparue ?
Rappelez-vous...
Il y a 8 millions d'années
la planète se refroidit,
l'eau est aspirée par les pôles,
une immense calotte de glace
se forme en Europe et en Asie.
Au nord, la vie commence
à s'acclimater au froid.
Sous |es tropiques, la nature assoiffée
cherche désespérément de l'humidité.
En Afrique, les grands singes
voient leur forêt disparaître.
Deux d'entre eux, Orrorin et Toumaï
s'adaptent a la savane
et inventent une nouvelle façon
de se déplacer:
ils se mettent debout.
Ils meurent il y a 4 millions d'années
en donnant naissance à d'autres espèces
mieux adaptées,
les australopithèques.
Lucy et ses congénères
se mettent en marche.
Ils survivent en se nourrissant
de végétaux de plus en plus coriaces
puis tombent à leur tour,
victimes de leur fragilité...
Cri
...et des prédateurs.
Alors arrive Homo Habilis,
l'homme habile,
le premier véritable
représentant du genre humain.
Il invente l'outil, commence
à agir sur le monde et à le parcourir.
Son évolution le change
en Homo Erectus, l'homme dressé,
le découvreur du feu.
Le pouvoir de l'homme fait un bond
immense dans le règne animal.
Erectus part
à la conquête du monde.
Il sort d'Afrique,
entre en Asie et en Europe.
Des dizaines de milliers d'hommes
et femmes, dispersés en groupes,
qui préparent sans le savoir,
l'arrivée de notre espèce...
Imaginez!
Nous sommes il y a 400 000 ans,
au cœur du continent africain.
Échange vocal
Homo Erectus marche parfois
jusqu'à 50km par jour pour survivre.
Il chasse de petits animaux,
cueille des baies et des racines
pour lui et les siens.
Parfois il meurt sur le chemin.
Au mieux, il vit jusqu'à 25 ou 30 ans.
La disparition d'un des leurs
est vécue comme une souffrance.
Mais Erectus ne sait rien
du mystère de la mort.
Où est parti le souffle ?
Pourquoi ne bouge-t-il plus ?
Et toujours derrière eux,
le danger qui menace...
Il faut marcher ou mourir,
c'est la loi.
La dépouille est abandonnée
aux animaux.
On se rappellera
quelque temps de l'être aimé.
Puis le souvenir s'évanouira.
Quand Erectus s'installe pour la nuit,
il construit des abris pour se protéger
et il fait un feu
pour écarter les prédateurs.
Il sait faire des outils.
Cela ne compte pas
pour |a femme qui porte l'enfant.
Voilà des jours
qu'elle mange des racines.
Elle a besoin de forces
pour celui qui bouge en elle.
Elle ne veut plus de ces racines.
Le chef Erectus sait
qu'il n'a pas trouvé de gibier,
il sait que ces racines sont amères
et ne calment pas |a faim.
Ce n'est pas une raison
pour le lui faire remarquer.
Erectus est curieux et
à l'affût de la moindre nouveauté.
Le chef a déjà entendu ce bruit,
mais aujourd'hui,
ce son qui résonne lui plaît.
Échange vocal
Mais soudain... ça ne résonne plus!
Ça ne résonne plus.
Ça y est !
Si on colle son oreille,
c'est beaucoup mieux.
Cri de satisfaction
Homo Erectus est chasseur.
Au petit matin, le chef et son frère
sont partis sur les traces prometteuses
d'une qui marche sur deux pattes.
Échange vocal
Mais la trouver ne suffit pas.
A la course,
elle est beaucoup trop rapide.
Alors on organise un stratagème.
Chacun son rôle.
Un qui rabat, l'autre qui attend.
Des termites jaunes.
Les jaunes,
lui, il ne peut pas résister.
Le chef connaît le caractère
de celle qui marche sur 2 pattes.
Avec ses œufs, c'est une maniaque.
Elle les connaît un par un.
S'il en manque, ne serait-ce
qu'un seul, c'est la crise.
Cris d'autruche
La chasse est lancée,
le piège va se refermer sur l'animal.
Mais que fait le frère ?
Si elle le rattrape, c'est la mort.
Ses pattes sont coupantes
comme des silex.
Hurlement
Cris de l'animal et de l'homme
Échange vocal
Son bec pique la peau
comme une pointe de lance.
Dispute
Le frère trouve toujours
un moyen pour tout gâcher.
On ne peut pas lui faire confiance.
L'animal ne peut plus fuir.
C'est une bonne chose.
Ce jour est un bon jour pour Erectus.
Cri de victoire
Erectus commence par manger
l'estomac, riche en végétaux,
puis il découpe l'animal pour
le transporter dans ses campements.
Les images de la capture
sont encore dans la tête du chef.
La bête est tombée dans le trou
et tout est devenu facile.
Il y a là une idée,
mais les mouches piquent
et l'empêchent de réfléchir.
Le corps d'Erectus
est de moins en moins velu.
Sa peau nue est soumise
aux agressions des insectes.
Surtout |es endroits sensibles.
Échange vocal
A cet endroit, le frère
n'est pas piqué par les mouches.
C'est la peau de l'animal !
Avec la peau,
les mouches ne piquent plus.
C'est peut-être comme cela
qu'Erectus a inventé l'habit.
Le partage de la viande
est soumis à la place
que chacun occupe
dans la hiérarchie du groupe.
Les chasseurs sont servis |es premiers,
puis viennent |es femelles préférées
auxquelles on réserve
un morceau de choix.
Celle qui porte l'enfant
a maintenant son gibier
et Erectus est conforté dans
sa fierté de chef et de protecteur.
Mais le pouvoir n'est jamais acquis,
on tourne le dos et quelqu'un est prêt
à vous prendre la place.
Sa peau, il a oublié sa peau.
C'est sa peau,
c'est sa place et il est le chef!
Il y a des choses
qu'on ne partage pas.
Comme la femme qui porte l'enfant,
comme la souffrance ou l'espoir.
Des images qui remplissent
sa tête est sortie celle d'un trou,
le chef veut en creuser un
là où les animaux viennent boire.
Pour qu'ils tombent dedans,
comme celle à deux pattes.
Mais de creuser la boue a donné
une nouvelle apparence à son corps.
Le chef est surpris.
Il ne reconnaît plus son frère.
Rires
Le rire est certainement
apparu a cette époque.
Un comportement qui aura de l'avenir.
Peut-être les premiers rires
de l'humanité
mais aussi la découverte du beau,
grâce à une trouvaille d'importance:
une pierre différente des autres.
Il la trouve belle.
Alors la pierre devient autre chose :
une parure qui fait plaisir à regarder.
Et sur lui
qu'est-ce que ça donne ?
Il n'est pas beau comme ça ?
Échange vocal
Beau et différent.
Maintenant c'est sa pierre.
C'est son signe, le signe du chef.
Le chef voudrait que celle
qui porte l'enfant regarde la pierre.
Mais ce n'est pas le moment,
la douleur est montée
dans le ventre de la femme.
Elle veut être seule pour ce moment
où l'enfant tombera de son ventre.
Elle sait ce qu'elle doit faire
sans l'avoir appris.
Elle crie de douleur.
Le chef est plein d'espoir:
le piège,
la peau qui protège, la pierre...
Mais l'enfant ?
Va-t-il arriver?
Une fois sur deux,
il vient sans le souffle,
comme ceux
qui tombent sur le chemin,
parfois les douleurs se terminent
par la mort de la femme.
La vie viendra-t-elle ?
Cri du bébé
Soupir de soulagement
Il est vivant.
C'est une petite fille.
Elle a une drôle de tête,
avec son front tout droit
et sa peau sans poils.
Elle a l'air si fragile et vulnérable.
Cri du bébé
Le chef ne veut pas
que le froid prenne son souffle.
Il sait maintenant,
sa peau n'est plus pour lui.
Sa peau est pour l'enfant.
Échange vocal
Sans le savoir,
ils ont donné naissance
à une nouvelle espèce d'hommes.
Une espèce
qui va les remplacer.
Homo Erectus sent peut-être
qu'il a fait son temps
et que l'avenir est là entre ses bras.
Échange vocal
Tonnerre
Homo Sapiens arrive.
Il va changer la vie des hommes
et conquérir le monde.
L'évolution d'Erectus en Sapiens s'est
faite en centaines de générations.
Son corps devient plus élancé .
Son front se redresse, son cerveau
est plus vaste, plus complexe.
Sapiens sort d'Afrique
et explore le Moyen-Orient.
Il s'habille, développe
son sens esthétique et ses outils.
Sa pensée et son imagination
vont faire de lui un autre homme.
Nous sommes à moins 100 000 ans.
Thème musical
Chœur
Les orages de chaleur sont les pires,
ils tuent à chaque fois.
Tonnerre
Mais d'où vient cette lumière
qui aveugle ?
Qui crache cette colère
qui fait trembler nos crânes ?
Un d'entre nous va trouver une réponse
au grand mystère de la mort.
Échange vocal
Il s'appelle Neeka le jeune.
Depuis qu'il sait chasser, Neeka
protège sa mère et sa petite sœur.
Le clan avait marché
depuis la venue du jour.
Le vent s'était levé soudainement
et le ciel s'était mis
à cracher du feu.
Le chef avait cherché un refuge,
mais rien !
On s'était serré
les uns contre les autres,
en attendant
que passe |a fureur de |a nature.
Tonnerre
Échange vocal
Naoki, la sœur de Neeka a eu peur.
Elle est partie sans prévenir.
Sa mère l'a suivie pour la protéger.
La tragédie va entrer
dans la vie de Neeka.
Tonnerre
Hurlement d'horreur
Échange vocal
De la foudre tombée sur la mère,
une bête à cornes est apparue.
Neeka l'a vue.
L'animal est parti
en laissant les corps
sur le sol.
Appel
Elles ne bougeaient plus.
Tous:
Neeka!
Échange vocal
Neeka n'avait pas su les protéger.
Il s'en voulait.
Il fallait qu'elles bougent,
qu'elles se remettent debout.
Pleurs
Notre chef a compris
que le souffle les avait quittés.
Mais Neeka ne voulait pas croire,
il refusait d'entendre et de voir
ce que tous voyaient.
Elles étaient mortes.
Il n'y avait rien à faire
et le chef voulait partir au plus vite.
Mais Neeka voulait
attendre qu'elles se réveillent.
Comme si c'était possible !
Échange vocal
Le chef ne comprenait pas,
mais il ne pouvait pas
abandonner Neeka.
Alors on s'est arrêté là.
Au début, c'était juste pour une nuit.
Thème musical lent
Échange vocal
Neeka pleure.
Sapiens est nomade.
Avec ses peaux, il fait des abris.
Son langage s'est perfectionné.
Il a des mots
pour parler des choses abstraites
comme du temps
derrière soi et du devant.
Son cerveau a plus de mémoire.
Il est capable de plus d'associations,
son imagination augmente.
Ses rêves sont plus impressionnants.
En dormant, il voyage
dans un autre monde,
un monde parallèle...
situé derrière les yeux.
Le clan dormait
quand une bête à cornes
est venue boire à la rivière.
Râle de l'animal
Le corps d'un animal de cette taille,
c'était de la viande pour tout le clan.
Pour Neeka,
cela ne faisait aucun doute,
c'était la même bête à cornes,
celle qui était venue la veille
dans la grande lumière.
Cris d'effort
Cette fois la,
le chef n'a pas été trop maladroit.
Gémissement de l'animal
Elle était blessée à mort.
Le chef était fier,
le clan aurait des semaines
de nourriture grâce à lui.
Mais ce n'est pas la viande
qui occupait les pensées de Neeka.
Dans le souffle
de l'animal qui s'enfuyait,
il entendait gémir la voix de sa sœur.
Gémissement de sa sœur
Gémissement de l'animal
Au moment où la bête perdait la vie,
l'inexplicable est arrivé.
Gémissement de la sœur
Le souffle de l'animal avait disparu
et celui de sa sœur était revenu.
Comment était-ce possible ?
Naoki respirait.
Naoki !
Elle retrouvait la vie.
Naoki...
Naoki !
Naoki !!
Naoki est revenue parmi nous.
Tout le monde s'est réjoui.
Mais Neeka était préoccupé,
il voulait comprendre
ce qui s'était passé.
Naoki ! Naoki ! Naoki !
Échange vocal
L'animal avait-il donné
son souffle a sa sœur?
La mort de l'animal avait-elle permis
de redonner la vie à Naoki ?
C'était un grand mystère.
Le chef aurait voulu
qu'on le félicite
mais le clan était fasciné
par le miracle de Neeka.
Neeka pleure.
Neeka avait un nouvel espoir.
Peut-être restait-il dans cette peau
du souffle de l'animal
pour le donner à sa mère.
Tout le monde s'est dit
que Neeka avait perdu la raison.
Ah !!!
Il suivait une idée fixe:
la bête à cornes
pouvait redonner vie à sa mère.
Appels de Neeka
Échange vocal
On espérait que la mère reviendrait
mais le comportement de Neeka
nous échappait.
Il ne mangeait pas.
Il restait près du corps
en attendant un signe.
Cris des vautours
Le signe est venu du ciel.
Comme toujours, les charognards
sont arrivés pour prendre le cadavre.
Mais Neeka refusait cela.
Si les vautours prenaient
la chair de sa mère,
aucun souffle ne pourrait y revenir.
Hé!
C'est peut-être ce jour-là,
qu'Homo Sapiens a inventé
la première sépulture.
Neeka crie.
Pour protéger le corps du défunt
et pour se protéger
de la vision de ce corps qui pourrit.
Car même sans les vautours,
le corps disparaissait petit a petit.
Échange vocal
Neeka! Neeka!
Neeka!
Le chef voulait que Neeka mange.
Il s'est déplacé pour lui offrir
un morceau de choix.
Ce qu'il ne fait jamais.
Il voulait que Neeka lui donne
le secret de sa magie.
Il voulait comprendre comment Neeka
avait donné vie à Naoki.
Mais il n'était pas
au bout de ses surprises.
Neeka ?
Neeka lui disait que sa mère vivait
dans un autre monde
et qu'elle devait manger.
Il divaguait!
Mais le jeune a donné
sa viande pour la mère.
C'en était trop.
Elle n'avait plus besoin de nourriture.
Elle était morte.
Ce monde, certains d'entre nous
ont commencé à y croire.
C'était le monde
dans lequel on allait en dormant.
On y croisait nos morts.
C'était le pays des songes.
Quelques jours plus tard,
3 d'entre nous ont quitté le clan.
Nous étions nombreux
et les conflits éclataient souvent.
Ils voulaient trouver un autre clan
et un autre chef.
Échange vocal
Celui-là, ils ne le supportaient plus.
Avant de partir, ils voulaient entendre
encore Neeka raconter les images
qu'il voyait derrière ses yeux.
Neeka!
Échange vocal
Ils voulaient écouter
le récit de la mère de Neeka,
pour ne pas l'oublier,
pour l'emporter avec eux.
Thème musical lent
Neeka raconte.
Neeka voyait l'autre monde,
celui où les morts allaient
quand le souffle les quittait.
Il voyait sa mère
avec la bête à cornes.
Sa mère le regardait,
comme pour dire que tout allait bien,
qu'elle n'avait plus faim,
qu'elle n'avait plus froid.
Derrière ses yeux, il y avait une lueur
qui disait
que |a vie continuait ailleurs.
Une vie après la mort.
Et cela change tout.
Ces croyances sont sans doute
|es prémices de la pensée religieuse.
Une extraordinaire composition
de l'imaginaire
qui dopera Sapiens
d'une force phénoménale:
la foi.
L'idée d'éternité va se répandre
chez tous les peuples
et apaiser l'angoisse de la mort.
L'homme peut s'engager
au-delà des limites de son existence.
Le temps des croyances
chamaniques est arrivé.
Le monde des esprits
côtoie celui des vivants.
Nous sommes entre moins 100 000
et moins 50 000 ans.
Sapiens explore
tous les territoires de la planète.
Certains vont vers |'Asie,
d'autres vers |'Europe.
Pourquoi se risquent-ils
dans un monde inconnu ?
Suivent-ils les migrations du gibier
ou les signes de la nature ?
Beaucoup croient au pouvoir
du soleil et de la lune.
Il y a 50 000 ans,
le premier groupe d'Homo Sapiens
arrive au sud de |'Europe.
Ce clan voue sa vie au soleil.
Sa disparition en plein jour
les terrifie.
Cris effrayés
Échange vocal
Une femme entre en transe pour lutter
contre les dévoreurs de lumière.
Cri de joie
Il revient.
Le soleil revient.
Échange vocal
La femme qui les guide est chaman.
Elle s'appelle Nata
et est l'aînée de trois sœurs.
Pour Nata, le soleil assombri
est un mauvais signe.
Les soleils doivent être forts
pour que vive le clan.
Il faut les suivre
derrière les montagnes
jusque dans le pays
où ils vont tous.
Face à l'immensité des Alpes,
ils devraient renoncer.
Pourtant, la foi les porte
et ils s'engagent
dans le plus périlleux des voyages.
Thème musical
Chœur
Cris de stupeur
Sapiens découvre la terre blanche
pour la première fois,
mais leurs pieds brûlent.
Échange vocal
C'est comme une peau sur les choses
qui prend la forme
de tout ce qui la touche.
Échange vocal
Alors pour se protéger du froid,
Sapiens invente la chaussure.
Rien n'arrête la détermination
de la chaman.
Il faut monter.
Leur peau se met à piquer,
leurs membres à geler.
Ils voudraient redescendre
mais personne n'ose défier Nata.
La chaman décide pour le clan.
Chez Sapiens,
le matriarcat est largement répandu.
Les femmes ont l'autorité,
elles sont responsables
de l'avenir du clan.
Les hommes suivent.
Le muet vient de perdre son oreille.
Il n'y a ni sang ni douleur.
Que faire de son oreille gelée ?
Comment la rattacher?
Le muet attend
l'avis de la femme Chaman.
Il n'y a rien à faire
sauf peut-être...
la manger.
Non g
Le muet préfère la manger.
Après tout, c'est son oreille.
Gémissements
Un soleil nouveau
s'est levé ce matin.
Ses premiers rayons n'apportent
ni chaleur, ni nourriture.
En allant vers les terres froides,
la peau de Sapiens s'est éclaircie
pour capter les rayons ultra-violets,
favoriser la synthèse
de vitamines essentielles
et sont adaptées
à une plus faible exposition au soleil,
mais pas à la haute montagne.
Échange vocal
Durant son sommeil, la première sœur
de Nata est partie dans l'autre monde.
Son corps froid est devenu dur
comme du bois.
Leurs croyances sont aussi nombreuses
que |es mystères de la nature.
Pour ce clan,
il n'y a pas de sépulture.
Ils offrent le corps
des défunts à la lumière.
Elle les mange
et les emmène au pays de l'autre vie.
Nata accompagne les morts
pour les aider à trouver le chemin.
Un jour, elle retrouvera sa sœur
dans le monde des soleils.
Ils continuent d'avancer.
Ils n'ont mangé que de la neige
depuis trois jours.
Nata leur a promis qu'au bout
du chemin, la nuit n'existait plus.
Cela leur donne du courage,
mais le courage
ne nourrit pas les plus faibles.
Cri de chagrin
Échange vocal
Chez Sapiens, tout le monde n'a pas
droit à une cérémonie.
Certains sont abandonnés
sans rites funéraires.
Nata sait la peine
qu'éprouve sa sœur,
elle ressent la souffrance de son clan,
mais ils ne peuvent pas s'arrêter.
Chœur
Comment ont-ils résisté?
Est-ce leurs habits en peaux
ou la graisse animale sur leur corps ?
La conquête des terres vierges
se paye au prix fort.
Sur le chemin,
Sapiens laisse beaucoup des siens.
Mais tous ces territoires explorés
profiteront aux prochaines générations.
Chœur et percussions
Ils sont désormais
moins que les doigts d'une main.
Alors que leur force les abandonne,
l'espoir renaît.
Trois formes recouvertes de neige,
certainement des animaux.
De la nourriture
pour aller jusqu'au bout du voyage.
Ils sont sauvés.
Des pierres...
Plusieurs pierres...
Que font ces pierres sur des animaux ?
Échange vocal
Une aile d'oiseau.
Mais elle n'a pas de chair.
D'autres hommes sont venus avant.
Mais qui sont-ils
et d'où viennent-ils ?
Pourquoi ces corps
emprisonnés sous la pierre ?
Leurs crânes ne ressemblent pas
aux nôtres.
Nata est perdue.
Le pays des soleils n'est pas ici.
Il n'y a rien à manger.
Ils sont condamnés.
Dans cet enfer,
personne ne peut survivre.
Échange vocal
Personne sauf peut-être
un être exceptionnel.
Dans cette Europe froide et hostile,
une autre espèce humaine
s'est parfaitement adaptée au milieu :
l'homme de Néandertal.
Nata et les siens viennent
d'entrer dans leur territoire.
Ils ont ouvert
les tombes de leurs ancêtres.
Néandertal est lui aussi
un descendant d'Homo Erectus.
Son ancêtre est arrivé en Europe
il y a 2 millions d'années.
Il s'est adapté
au froid qui s'installait
et est devenu une force de la nature.
Le chef Néandertal a décidé
de ramener les étrangers au camp.
Quand Nata ouvre les yeux,
elle ne sait plus
si elle est dans le monde des vivants.
Qui sont ces gens qui ne sont pas
tout à fait des hommes ?
Sans jamais avoir été
en contact avec Sapiens,
Néandertal aussi fait de son côté
de nombreuses découvertes :
le monde invisible, les croyances,
la musique, le feu.
Il vit dans des cavernes
et enterre ses morts.
Nata et |es siens ont été recueillis
parle clan de la lune.
Leur chef veut savoir
qui a osé déterrer ses ancêtres.
Le visage de Nata l'intrigue.
Qui sont ces êtres au front plat?
Il faut qu'ils reviennent à la vie.
Celui qui mène le clan de la lune
veut tout savoir sur eux.
Elle hurle.
La chaman reprend conscience
mais ce qu'elle découvre est si étrange
et différent de ce qu'elle sait.
Échange vocal
Que font-ils de son compagnon ?
Ils ne peuvent pas faire ça.
Il doit rester avec elle,
elle a besoin de lui.
Différence de culture,
de langage, de mode de vie...
Pour ces Sapiens, les cultes
de Néandertal sont des sacrilèges.
Pourtant sa culture n'est pas
moins riche ni moins belle.
Le lendemain, l'odeur de la viande
grillée réveille Nata et sa sœur.
La faim est plus forte que tout.
Depuis la neige, elles ont tout oublié.
Où sont-elles ?
Qui les a amenées ici ?
Les images
de ces hommes aux gros nez
peuplent les pensées de Nata.
Échange vocal
Qui sont ces gens ?
Les souvenirs
de son périple repassent.
Samke !
Ce n'était pas un rêve.
Et Samke, où est-il ?
Samke !
Nata se souvient de l'endroit
où ils ont enfermé son compagnon.
Elle ne sait pas ce qu'est une tombe.
Natal
Ils l'ont caché,
comme un gibier qu'on conserve,
comme les squelettes dans la neige.
Samke !
Samke est mort.
Elle hurle.
Elle le rend à la lumière
pour que son esprit parte
avec le vent des montagnes.
incantations
Pour survivre
pendant la froidure de l'hiver,
Néandertal se nourrit
principalement de viande.
Il est le plus grand chasseur
de la planète.
Échange vocal
En rentrant à la caverne,
une surprise attend le chef.
Le mort enterré la veille est parti.
Il a fui.
Où es-tu ?
Montre-toi !
Il est peut-être entré dans la terre ?
Échange vocal
Voix de femme
Quelle est cette voix étrange ?
Est-ce lui qui appelle ?
Cris de femme
Son mort était là et la femme criait.
Le chef Néandertal ne comprend pas
la transe de Nata,
mais il est surpris
par les mouvements de son corps.
Échange vocal
Nata et sa sœur resteront
avec le clan de la lune.
Thème musical
Chœur
Sans le savoir, ces Sapiens auront
découvert un nouveau continent:
L'Europe.
Cette traversée des Alpes
a ouvert la route
et d'autres suivront
les traces de ces pionniers.
Cette rencontre n'est que la première.
D'autres suivront.
Dans quelques millénaires,
Sapiens et Néandertal vivront ensemble
une aventure exceptionnelle:
celle de la grande chasse.
Au même moment
de l'autre côté de la planète,
Homo Sapiens découvre |'Asie.
Avec la glaciation,
le niveau des océans est alors
120 mètres plus bas qu'aujourd'hui.
Les îles d'Asie du sud-est
sont reliées entre elles.
Homo Sapiens va pousser son voyage
jusqu'à la limite des terres.
Au cours de ses migrations,
Sapiens a changé d'apparence,
|es environnements
ont modifié la forme de ses yeux,
de son nez et la couleur de sa peau.
Il a découvert un nouveau
et fabuleux moyen pour se déplacer:
la navigation.
Depuis des générations,
le clan de la rivière
a fait des fleuves le centre de sa vie.
Pour eux, l'eau est sacrée,
elle est la direction
qui les protège contre les dangers.
Voilà des mois qu'ils descendent
ce cours d'eau,
ils ont traversé
la péninsule indonésienne
sans avoir croisé un seul clan.
Pourtant, un autre humain
est là depuis longtemps
et il observe tous leurs gestes.
Cet être humain est aussi
un descendant d'Homo Erectus.
Arrivé ici il y a presque
2 millions d'années,
il a évolué en plusieurs sous espèces
qui peuplent toute |'Asie,
homme de Pékin, homme de Java
ou homme de Florès.
Chacun d'entre eux est adapté
à son milieu.
Échange vocal
Le jeune est le seul à l'avoir vu
et personne ne veut le croire.
Le clan de |a rivière
ne s'arrête jamais de naviguer.
Ils suivent le sens de l'eau,
se laissent porter par les courants
de cette veine qui devient chaque jour
plus large.
Il y a 60 000 ans,
le clan de la rivière arrive
au bout des terres d'Asie
et découvre l'Océan Pacifique
pour la première fois.
Pour eux, cette étendue d'eau
est un nouveau fleuve
dont on ne voit pas l'autre rive.
Ils n'ont jamais vu ça,
ils sont fascinés
par ces vagues immenses,
par ce son
qui fait trembler leur corps.
Échange vocal
Le chef veut trouver
le chemin jusqu'au bout de l'eau.
Il a décidé de partager le clan
en deux groupes.
Il part
avec son chaman et sa famille
et reviendra
chercher le reste du clan.
Échange vocal
Homo Sapiens ne sait pas
encore qu'en face de lui,
des milliers de kilomètres d'eaux
profondes sont prêts à l'engloutir.
Emporté par sa foi,
ce petit groupe
s'élance à la conquête d'un océan
dont il ignore
toute la monstruosité.
Ceux qui restent ont installé
leur campement.
Trois femmes et un enfant protégés
par un seul guerrier:
Œil de serpent,
le plus habile pêcheur du clan.
Depuis leur installation, l'homme
curieux est venu plusieurs fois.
Toujours le même.
Et il fait toujours la même chose.
Échange vocal
Œil de serpent veut le rencontrer.
Il sait qu'il faut apprivoiser
ceux qui viennent d'ailleurs
pour éviter qu'ils ne deviennent
mauvais ou dangereux.
Appel
L'homme repart toujours,
son attitude est incompréhensible.
Cette fois-ci, Œil de serpent
a décidé d'agir différemment.
Il sait qu'aucun homme
n'a réussi à le prendre de vitesse.
Dans cette jungle asiatique,
il sait lire tous les signaux,
décrypter les cris des animaux
et localiser n'importe
quelle créature à distance.
Il est là tout près.
Que veut-il ?
Œil de serpent s'est fait capturer
comme un buffle aveugle.
Échange vocal
Il est tombé dans
les griffes d'un génie de la forêt.
Ces Homo Erectus sont
de formidables chasseurs.
Leurs règles pour la survie
dans un milieu hostile préconisent
que tout être vivant est mangeable.
Même les humains...
Dans certaines circonstances.
Échange vocal
Ils l'ont capturé
comme ils auraient pris un bel oiseau.
Pour l'instant, ils regardent
ses plumes et ses couleurs,
ils l'invitant à partager leur repas.
Mais de quel sang s'agit-il ?
Vont-ils après cela le tuer
et le manger à son tour?
Œil de serpent doit rester calme.
Ceux qui naviguent vers l'autre rive
ont été emportés.
Les vents et les courants
les éloignent de toute terre.
Quand ils se réveillent ce matin-là,
il n'y a plus aucune rive.
Ni d'un côté ni de l'autre.
Il n'y a plus un seul oiseau
dans le ciel.
Échange vocal
Le monde a disparu.
Le fleuve géant a tout recouvert.
Ils dérivent lentement
vers |'Antarctique.
Voix d'homme qui appelle
Œil de serpent est vivant.
Ils sont sauvés.
Échange vocal
Œil de serpent a excité
la curiosité de ces chasseurs.
Ils veulent en savoir plus sur
les secrets de ces hommes peints
qui marchent sur l'eau,
sur le pouvoir de leurs coquillages
et de leurs hameçons.
Échange vocal
Le chef n'est pas revenu.
Que faire s'il ne rentre pas ?
Affaibli par le manque d'eau,
le chaman vient de mourir.
Ses croyances se sont effondrées.
Souvent,
face à la violence de la nature,
Homo Sapiens doute
de la raison de son existence.
Ceux qui marchent sur l'eau échangent
leur savoir avec ceux de |a forêt.
L'art de la parure,
les techniques de pêche,
la fabrication des outils
et des habits...
Des liens se forment entre eux
malgré l'éloignement génétique.
Il est probable
que sur le continent asiatique,
Sapiens et Erectus se soient mélangés
pour former
la grande famille des peuples d'Asie.
A des centaines de kilomètres,
|es navigateurs sont a bout de forces,
déshydratés et brûlés par le soleil.
Appel
La terre.
L'autre côté du grand fleuve.
Le monde est revenu,
il est remonté des profondeurs.
Ils ont navigué
pendant des jours et des jours.
Grâce aux courants,
a leur inconscience et leur audace,
ils arrivent épuisés sur une terre
que l'homme n'a jamais foulée.
Peut-être croient-ils avoir atteint
le monde secret de leurs rêves ?
Il y a soixante mille ans,
Homo Sapiens découvre l'Australie.
Une terre immense détachée du reste
du monde depuis des millions d'années.
Le berceau d'espèces
animales et végétales uniques.
Ils navigueront
de nombreuses fois sur l'océan
sans jamais retrouver leur chemin.
Ils seront à l'origine
d'une autre grande famille humaine.
Un peuple
d'extraordinaires navigateurs.
La famille du Pacifique.
Dans le reste de |'Asie,
les migrations continuent.
Homo Sapiens traverse la Chine
et passe en Amérique à pied
par le détroit de Béring.
Il découvre un autre nouveau
continent, vaste et riche en gibier.
Il pousse son chemin
jusqu'en Amérique du Sud.
Pendant ce temps, Sapiens entre
en Europe par vagues successives,
il s'adapte
a |a vie glaciaire dans |a toundra.
Nous sommes à moins 40 000 ans.
L'hiver européen est terrible,
balayé par les vents glacials.
La seule nourriture pour l'homme
est la viande.
Les troupeaux ne sont pas
au rendez-vous.
Parfois même, ils disparaissent
et |a famine s'installe.
Sapiens déplace ses campements
en espérant trouver du gibier.
Il vit dans des tipis faits de peaux
et de branches
qu'il plante au sommet des collines
pour guetter le moindre animal.
Échange vocal
Dans ces moments de carence,
|es femmes n'ont plus de lait
pour nourrir leurs enfants
et ils meurent
les uns après les autres.
Le chef du clan des rennes n'a trouvé
qu'un lapin mort de froid.
Ce n'est pas avec ça qu'il va nourrir
ses deux femmes et son clan.
Le clan des rennes est en train
de devenir le clan du silence.
inlassablement,
Akyia le chef parcourt les alentours
à la recherche
du moindre cri animal.
Croassement
Même la chair dure et puante
de l'oiseau noir est une aubaine.
Avec sa nouvelle arme,
le propulseur,
il ne rate jamais une cible
à cette distance.
Ah !!!
Cris guerriers
Échange vocal
Il veut savoir qui elle est
et pourquoi elle se trouve là.
La femme ne comprend pas,
elle veut son collier.
Elle a un curieux visage.
Ces bosses au-dessus des yeux.
Comme si elle s'était cognée.
Cette femme fait partie
du peuple Néandertal.
Eux aussi souffrent
du manque de gibier.
Elle aime les coquillages du collier
de Sapiens, elle n'a jamais vu ça.
Il est pris tout entier par son désir
de la toucher, de la sentir.
Maintenant,
il veut s'emparer d'elle.
Il crie.
Jamais une femme
ne lui a résisté de la sorte.
Lui, Akyia,
le chef du clan des rennes.
Croassement
Au petit matin des cris d'animaux
ont retenti près du campement.
Des cris
comme ils n'en ont jamais entendu.
Et là devant eux, descendant du nord,
des animaux énormes, couverts de
longs poils et armés de dents immenses.
Ce sont des "longs nez".
Le chaman le sait.
Il y en avait beaucoup autrefois.
Des grands troupeaux.
Ils avaient disparu.
Toute cette viande si proche
mais comment faire pour les tuer ?
Échange vocal
Le vieux fou veut les affronter,
cela ne rassure pas le chef.
Le chaman trouve toujours les mots.
Il fera venir l'esprit des ancêtres
et donnera |a force aux chasseurs.
Akiya vaincra, le chaman le sait.
Les Mammouths occupent la terre
depuis des millions d'années.
Pour ces pachydermes comme pour
les hommes, la glaciation est un fléau.
inlassablement,
ils parcourent des distances énormes
pour trouver les 200 kilos de fourrage
dont ils ont besoin chaque jour.
Le chaman reste
au sommet de la montagne,
il parle aux gens invisibles.
incantations
Esprits, donnez
courage à nos chasseurs.
Tuez pour nous ces géants.
Akyia sait tuer le renne,
le cerf, le cochon.
Jamais il n'a osé
s'attaquer a pareille puissance.
Barrissement
Face à ces monstres ils ne sont rien.
La peur fait battre les cœurs.
Mais leurs estomacs crient.
L'odeur de la viande fait saliver
leurs bouches et courir leurs jambes.
Cris guerriers
Échange vocal
Ils sont trop rapides.
Ils se méfient de l'homme.
Ils le fuient.
Barrissement
Ils le fuient
et se retrouvent bloqués,
contraints de se retourner
et de |'affronter.
Et là, leur peur les rend
encore plus dangereux.
Sauf l'un d'entre eux, plus jeune,
et effrayé par les cris humains.
Il ne veut pas revenir sur ses pas.
incantations
Barrissement
Maintenant,
le combat devient inévitable.
Hurlement
Barrissement
Cri de désespoir
Échange vocal
Ils ont perdu la chasse.
Un d'entre eux a perdu le souffle.
Mais il y a encore un espoir.
Là-bas.
Un groupe de Néandertal.
Ils sont aussi venus pour tuer.
Ils ont un avantage
sur le clan des rennes,
ils connaissent le pouvoir
du feu sur les longs nez.
Cri de la femme
Barrissement
La femme Néandertal
effraie le dernier Mammouth.
Il doit rebrousser chemin.
Il y a encore une chance,
une dernière.
Échange vocal
Leurs sagaies ne sont rien contre
la dureté de la peau de l'animal.
Mais ils n'ont pas le choix.
Le jeune Mammouth fonce
vers la sortie.
Mais Néandertal est là.
Si Néandertal sait qu'il peut affronter
une bête isolée,
il sait aussi que ça ne suffit pas.
Il faut lui couper toute retraite.
Cris d'attaque
Néandertal est le plus grand
des chasseurs,
mais un mal ronge son corps.
Barrissement
Le long nez est bloqué.
Pour la première fois, Sapiens
et Néandertal sont unis
autour d'une même proie.
Poussés
par le même instinct de survie,
ces hommes et ces femmes
ferment toute retraite au géant.
Il faut l'empêcher de bouger
et restreindre son espace.
La femme Néandertal n'est plus
en compétition avec l'homme Sapiens.
Ça y est.
Il est a la merci des lances.
Il faut frapper
dans les endroits vulnérables.
L'aine et l'anus
où la peau est moins épaisse.
Cris de joie
Barrissement
incantations
Le chaman remerciera
les ancêtres jusqu'à la nuit.
Grâce à eux, le clan des rennes a
inventé une nouvelle façon de chasser.
La grande chasse organisée.
Cette nouveauté aura des conséquences
considérables sur la vie des hommes.
Avec la viande du mammouth,
les 2 clans ont de la nourriture
comme ils n'en ont jamais eue.
Ils peuvent rester des mois
sans chasser.
Pour la première fois,
les hommes ont du temps devant eux.
Du temps libre
pour penser, expérimenter et faire
des choses apparemment inutiles.
Écho
Échange vocal, rires
Néandertal et Sapiens se retrouvent
autour d'un repas
avec de nouveaux sentiments.
Ceux de l'entraide, de la solidarité...
et de l'attirance.
La femme Néandertal veut le chef
du clan des rennes pour elle.
Mais Akyia a 2 compagnes
et rien ne se fera
sans l'accord de ses femmes.
Échange vocal
Elles sont d'accord.
Désormais elles vivront ensemble.
Les clans ont beaucoup
a apprendre l'un de l'autre
et cela passera par un long
apprentissage du langage.
Petit à petit...
Ountourè.
Mot par mot...
Ountouré ?
- Ountoué !
- Ountoé.
-Ountoué!
-Ountoé!
Ountoa!
Ountoii!
Ountoa !!
Ountoé !!!
La découverte de la coopération
pour les grandes chasses
prépare un rapprochement
entre |es hommes d'origines diverses.
Bientôt des liens nouveaux
vont voir le jour:
mariages, alliances...
Les racines de la société.
Ce soir, Akyia veut prendre
celle qui le rend fort
et heureux.
Quel est ce mal
qui fait saigner son nez ?
La femme Néandertal souffre
mais ils se plaisent
et ils veulent mieux se connaître.
Échange vocal
Cette alliance ne plaît pas
au chaman.
Il se méfie de la femme Néandertal.
Gémissements
Cette femme et cet homme
appartiennent au genre humain
mais ils ne sont pas
de la même espèce.
Leur union ne peut donner
de descendance.
Ils sont génétiquement différents.
L'esprit de la femme
a volé celui de son chef.
Il faut protéger le clan
et communiquer avec la pensée d'Akyia.
Ce soir-là, le feu projette l'ombre
du chapeau du chef sur le rocher.
Pour le chaman, c'est la partie
animale qui est dans le chef
et elle danse sur la pierre.
Il la voit.
Il veut garder le souvenir
de ce moment magique.
Alors, il en suit les contours
avec du charbon de bois.
L'esprit est là.
L'esprit d'Akyia reste sur la pierre.
Il l'a repris à la femme.
Il y a quarante mille ans,
la première représentation
symbolique est fixée sur de la pierre.
La naissance de l'art.
Cette invention aura bientôt
une portée universelle.
Thème musical
Échange vocal
Quelques années ont passé.
Les deux clans
ont fait route ensemble,
mais presque tous les Néandertal
sont morts du mal qui les affecte.
Ils ne sont plus que trois
dont la femme du chef.
Échange vocal
Elle n'en peut plus.
Elle doit rester là.
C'est la fin du voyage.
Elle tousse.
Aucun enfant n'est venu de son ventre.
Le clan ne peut s'arrêter,
l'hiver les talonne,
il faut marcher vers le sud.
Elle le rejette.
Akiya g
Le temps presse.
Akiya est celui qui marche devant
et il doit se conduire comme tel.
Penser avant tout
a l'avenir du clan des rennes.
Epuisée par les fièvres,
la femme veut se reposer
et refroidir son corps
dans l'eau glacée.
Elle tousse.
Gémissements de douleur
Néandertal se meurt.
Les humains de cette espèce vont
peu à peu disparaître de la terre,
fauchés par les maladies,
par une réduction des naissances,
cela reste encore un mystère.
incantations
Akyia ne veut plus entendre
les prières du chaman.
Croassement
Peut-être se doute-t-il
de la fragilité de notre espèce.
Hurlement
Néandertal disparaît.
La chasse aux grands mammifères
se répand.
Sur toute la planète,
le rythme de vie change.
Plus de temps libre, de créations.
Homo Sapiens sculpte ses objets,
fabrique des parures
et décore ses outils.
Une véritable explosion culturelle.
Dans certains endroits, une création
humaine surpuissante voit le jour:
L'Art Pariétal.
L'art va devenir un message.
Nous sommes en France,
il y a 20 000 ans.
Homo Sapiens est dispersé
en Europe.
Parfois, il souffre d'isolement.
Des clans n'arrivent pas a se mélanger
avec d'autres populations.
Ils se reproduisent entre eux
sur une, deux, trois générations.
La consanguinité
frappe leurs enfants,
|es rendent incapables de se reproduire
et d'assurer l'avenir du clan.
Voilà des années
qu'Atka le sorcier
veut guérir
les siens de cette malédiction.
Mais l'ancêtre qui les guide
reste muet, il ne répond plus.
Atka a-t-il perdu son pouvoir?
Qu'est-ce qu'un sorcier
s'il ne soigne pas son clan ?
Atka se sent seul,
isolé du reste du groupe,
avec son fils sur les bras.
Autrefois le clan des chasseurs
de bisons était prospère.
Il y avait 8 chasseurs,
12 femmes et de nombreux enfants.
Aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus
que 9 et un seul enfant mâle.
S'il ne trouve pas
une solution, le clan disparaîtra.
Le chef
a découvert un abri pour l'hiver.
Le fils d'Atka est agité.
Comme si ce lieu lui parlait,
comme s'il entendait des voix.
Cri de l'enfant
Thème musical lent
La caverne est accueillante :
spacieuse, proche de l'eau
et abritée du vent.
Elle a la forme d'un crâne.
Échange vocal
Des feux ont été allumés ici.
Et là des gens ont dormi,
ont mangé.
D'autres ont vécu ici avant eux.
Où sont-ils à présent?
L'enfant a repéré le passage.
C'était sa maladie,
il cherchait toujours à se cacher,
pour être en dehors du monde.
Atka sent une présence.
Qui se cache au fond
du ventre de la caverne ?
Des ours ? Des lions ?
Ou des humains ?
La roche répond à sa voix.
Écho
Les grottes sont les meilleurs endroits
pour les rituels chamaniques.
Celle-ci lui paraît propice.
Il appelle.
Mais il sent autre chose, là!
Juste à côté de lui.
Des signes.
Faits par la main de l'homme.
Les premiers ornements rupestres.
Ils figurent des stries,
des cercles, des spirales...
Ces formes sont
les visions d'un chaman
dans le premier stade
de sa transe hallucinatoire.
Ils étaient là,
d'autres mains d'hommes
ont gravé cette roche.
Que s'est-il passé ici ?
Ont-ils voulu laisser un message ?
Thème musical
Atka sait prendre |es forces cachées
dans |es racines, |es insectes.
Il en fait des couleurs pour sa
peinture et des potions pour soigner.
Grâce à eux, il pourra retrouver
l'esprit égaré de son fils.
Il veut le ramener à côté de lui
dans le monde du visible.
Cette limace donne la vision.
Elle permet d'atteindre
les profondeurs de l'âme
et de voyager dans l'invisible.
Là où se cache l'esprit de son enfant.
incantations
Son ancêtre sorcier
lui avait tout appris.
En retournant à la nature
il y a bien longtemps,
il était devenu bison.
Mais son esprit guidait toujours Atka.
Il fait appel
à la force de l'animal.
Il lui demande de l'aider
pour guérir son enfant.
Cri
Cette limace a agi rapidement,
elle est efficace.
L'enfant résiste.
Il ne veut pas se laisser attraper.
Il fuit.
Atka le suit pas à pas.
Il ne le laissera pas s'échapper.
Cri de l'enfant
Au-dessus de la transe, le clan
s'est installé pour le repas.
Ce qu'ils attendent depuis des années
est arrivé.
Des hommes et des femmes
d'un autre clan.
ceux qui viennent d'ailleurs.
La chance
est avec nous.
C'est leur caverne.
Ils ne veulent pas d'autre clan.
Ils ne veulent pas partager.
Alors que les bras vont frapper,
l'esprit du bison
s'empare du corps d'Atka.
Échange de cris
Cette femme porte
les signes des sorciers.
Échange vocal
Elle a entendu
les appels d'Atka
dans les profondeurs
du crâne en pierre.
incantations du sorcier
Le sorcier n'est plus Atka.
Son corps ne lui appartient plus.
Ses mouvements sont ceux de l'animal.
La sorcière l'a compris,
elle entre dans sa transe.
La main d'Atka trace les contours
d'une nouvelle image
devant les yeux des étrangers.
Les hommes des deux clans
sont pris par le spectacle.
Ils cessent de se battre
et attendent la suite.
Cris de transe
l'image prend une forme
qu'ils connaissent.
Elle leur rappelle une émotion
qu'ils ont déjà vécue.
Ils se regardent,
ils ressentent la même chose
et cela leur va droit dans le cœur.
Tout bouge et se transforme.
Est-ce grâce à la lueur des flammes
ou à la danse du sorcier?
Ils voient l'esprit de l'animal,
il avance, il marche.
Ils l'entendent même.
Ils vivent ensemble
l'intérieur de l'âme humaine.
La peinture des cavernes est un langage
qui permet aux Homo Sapiens
de se comprendre et de s'accepter.
Elle sera un message universel
qui touche le cœur des hommes
et les rend tous solidaires.
Rires
Échange vocal
Ils s'entraident,
ils échangent leurs savoirs,
ils trouvent une meilleure façon
de se protéger des vents glacials.
Ils préparent ensemble
l'arrivée de l'hiver.
Atka n'a pas pu retrouver
l'esprit perdu de l'enfant.
Pas encore.
Échange vocal
Les sorciers échangent leurs
secrets sur |es plantes médicinales.
A deux,
ils sont deux fois plus savants.
Ils commencent la grande collecte
des mystères de la nature.
De ce savoir immense
naîtra un jour la médecine.
Entre - 30 000 et - 20 000 ans
des chefs-d'œuvre apparaissent,
à des milliers de kilomètres
les uns des autres.
Comme si les Homo Sapiens
s'étaient donné le mot.
L'art rassemble des groupes et
les fédère en communautés plus vastes.
Des populations immenses vont s'unifier
pour devenir des peuples.
Soudain,
il y a douze mille ans,
la température monte.
C'est le début d'un changement
climatique majeur.
Les deux tiers de la glace
retenue aux pôles fondent.
Le niveau des océans
remonte de 120 mètres.
Les continents prennent
les formes qu'on connaît aujourd'hui.
Une époque grandiose
de la vie des hommes s'achève.
Mais une nouvelle commence.
La température devient clémente,
l'eau abondante et |a terre généreuse.
Sapiens découvre des régions si riches
en gibier et en plantes comestibles
qu'il s'arrête de marcher.
Il construit des villages de pierres
faits pour durer.
C'est pour beaucoup la fin d'une vie
nomade qui remonte à toujours.
Avec la sédentarisation,
tout va changer.
Échange vocal
Nous sommes en Mésopotamie,
il y a dix mille ans.
Ecoute mon histoire,
elle a bouleversé la vie des hommes.
Ma mère était jeune alors.
Les nôtres ne connaissaient pas
ce que l'on sait aujourd'hui.
Neneh était
un homme apprécié de tous
et particulièrement de ma mère.
Il s'arrêtait pour |a voir
quand il rentrait de |a chasse
et il lui apportait
des œufs d'oiseaux.
Depuis quelque temps,
la vie était moins dure pour les gens.
Ils commençaient à prendre du temps
pour être heureux ensemble.
Ma mère était amoureuse de Neneh.
Et Neneh était amoureux de ma mère.
Ils ne cachaient pas leur affection
a |a vue de tous...
Même si ça amusait tout le monde.
Surtout le chef du village.
Cela faisait à peine deux lunes
qu'ils étaient ensemble.
Ils étaient heureux
et insouciants.
Chants
Ce jour-là pourtant,
elle avait eu un pressentiment.
En ce temps-là, nous devions aller
dans la montagne
pour cueillir les blés sauvages.
C'était |a fin de l'été
et l'on devait ramasser des grains
pour passer l'hiver.
Neneh savait qu'en cette saison
le faucon pondait ses œufs.
Ma mère aimait tellement les œufs.
Cet homme, il y a dix mille ans,
connaît parfaitement |a nature.
Elle ne le fait plus souffrir.
Elle est pleine
de surprises merveilleuses
et il commence à jouer avec elle.
Neneh!
Appel
Elle ne l'a pas vu partir.
Elle croit qu'il lui joue un tour.
Neneh !!
Échange vocal
Puis elle se souvient
de son pressentiment.
Neneh!
Homo Sapiens joue avec la nature.
Mais quand il va trop loin,
la nature refuse de jouer.
Hurlement
La montagne a avalé le corps de Neneh.
Ma mère le cherche...
En vain...
Neneh ! Neneh!
Ils entendent le cri du loup.
Ils prennent peur pour Neneh.
Neneh !!!
Mieux valait rester ensemble,
si les loups étaient nombreux.
On craignait les loups.
Neneh!
Un faible gémissement
Tous:
Neneh!
Une plainte...
Un homme qui gémit...
Elle sent que Neneh est là
tout proche d'elle.
Ce ne n'est pas Neneh,
mais le plus étrange spectacle
qui lui ait été donné de voir.
Un petit d'homme
avec une louve des montagnes.
Le plus féroce des carnassiers.
Les loups étaient à côté de nous
depuis toujours.
Quand nos enfants se perdaient dans
|a forêt, les loups les dévoraient.
Nous n'aimions pas les loups.
Surtout notre chef,
il en avait tué plus d'un.
Mais il n'a pas le temps
de s'occuper de celui-là.
Il entend à son tour
|es gémissements de l'enfant.
Grognement
Échange vocal
L'enfant est farouche,
certainement abandonné
par un autre clan.
Ma mère veut le réconforter
mais il refuse.
Assez !
Le chef en a vu d'autres
et ce n'est pas cet enfant
qui va changer l'ordre des choses.
Occupés parle sort de l'enfant,
ils cessent de chercher Neneh.
De toute manière s'il était par la,
il leur répondrait.
Homo Sapiens vit
dans de petites huttes de pierres,
rassemblées
autour d'un grenier commun.
Le premier village.
Les premières maisons.
Ma mère a pris l'enfant avec elle
et l'a installé sur la couche de Neneh.
Mais l'enfant ne veut pas dormir.
Gémissement
Il écoute la montagne.
Elle ne pouvait pas croire
que la louve était la mère de l'enfant.
Sa mère animale.
On n'avait encore jamais vu ça.
Ma mère avait
beaucoup d'amour a donner.
Peut-être trop pour elle toute seule.
♪ étais cet enfant sauvage,
je ne me sentais pas homme,
je me prenais pour un loup.
Ma mère animale m'avait recueilli.
Dans ce premier village,
Homo Sapiens partage les tâches.
Chacun travaille pour la communauté.
Les peaux servent de récipients.
Les pierres chauffées au feu
font bouillir les marmites.
Les femmes pensent aux hommes.
Il n'y a plus vraiment de clan
mais plusieurs familles
et chaque famille a son foyer.
On se rend service, on se rend visite.
La polygamie a tendance a disparaître.
La famille se resserre
autour du couple.
Un homme et une femme,
leurs enfants et parfois leurs parents.
La famille d'aujourd'hui
est en train de naître.
Et celle dont rêvait ma mère
vient de disparaître.
Aucune trace de Neneh.
Personne ne l'a vu,
personne ne l'a entendu...
Ma mère avait besoin d'aimer,
besoin de donner.
Elle ne pouvait rester seule
sans partager sa vie.
Cri de l'enfant
Échange vocal
Je ne voulais personne près de moi,
je ne supportais pas
qu'on me touche,
ni le contact et l'odeur des habits.
Je n'acceptais que sa présence.
Mais pas la viande noire de feu
qu'elle voulait me faire manger.
Peu a peu elle s'attachait
a l'enfant sauvage.
Elle s'attachait à moi.
♪ étais en train de prendre
une place dans son cœur.
La place d'un fils...
La louve est revenue un beau jour
pour réclamer son fils.
Gémissement
La louve hurle.
Elle m'avait nourri,
protégé, réchauffé,
depuis que j'étais un nouveau-né.
Les hommes n'aiment pas les loups
parce qu'ils ne les connaissent pas.
Jamais ma mère louve
ne m'aurait fait de mal.
Mais ils me croyaient
en danger avec elle,
comme le sont tous les enfants
avec tous les loups.
Échange vocal
Elle a été la première à comprendre.
Elle parle doucement.
Peut-être parce qu'elle ressentait
l'amour de l'animal.
Parce qu'elle souffrait de
l'absence de celui qu'elle avait aimé.
Doux grognement
♪ avais maintenant deux mères
et je ne savais pas laquelle choisir.
Gémissement
Langage apaisant
Gémissement apaisé
Échange vocal
Échange vocal apaisé
Elle a su parler au loup
comme à l'enfant.
Échange vocal
Échange vocal tendre
Voilà comment ma mère est
devenue ma mère, pour toute la vie.
Elle chante une berceuse.
Une année a passé.
♪ ai grandi avec les hommes.
La louve est restée près du village
et petit à petit, elle s'est habituée
à la présence des hommes.
Une alliance est née
entre l'homme et l'animal.
Ça a été le début
d'une grande aventure,
avec les loups
mais aussi avec d'autres animaux.
Échange vocal
Il y a douze mille ans,
le loup rejoint
la communauté des hommes,
mais il faudra des générations
de loups nés chez les hommes
pour qu'ils deviennent
ce que nous appelons le chien.
Thème musical
Grâce à ma mère-louve,
nous avons fait d'autres découvertes.
L'enfant crie.
Un corps mort depuis longtemps
gisait au milieu des blés sauvages.
Neneh!
Cri de désespoir
C'était la dépouille de Neneh.
Échange vocal
Il avait disparu le jour
où ma mère m'avait trouvé.
Elle m'avait donné l'amour
qu'elle avait pour lui.
C'était son collier.
Ma mère a tout de suite su
ce qu'elle devait en faire.
Les grains de blés qui étaient
dans |a besace de Neneh avaient germé.
La où ils étaient tombés,
ils avaient poussé.
Le chef compris
que chaque grain s'était reproduit
en une multitude d'autres.
C'était si simple,
mais on n'y avait jamais pensé.
Ma mère m'a donné le collier de Neneh.
♪ ai grandi toute ma vie avec.
Jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Ce collier te revient désormais,
à toi.
le fils de mon fils. Porte-le
et transmets-le à ceux
qui viendront après toi.
Raconte cette histoire aux hommes
afin qu'ils ne l'oublient jamais.
Chant à plusieurs voix
Nous sommes il y a dix mille ans.
Grâce à ces 2 fabuleuses découvertes,
la vie des hommes va basculer.
L'agriculture se propage
sur toute la terre en quelques siècles.
Homo Sapiens s'installe
à proximité de ses cultures,
il calque sa vie
sur le rythme des saisons,
récoltant le fruit de son travail.
La domestication du loup est suivie
par celle de nombreux autres animaux.
Homo Sapiens découvre l'élevage
qui procure
une alimentation sûre et abondante.
Dans de nombreux endroits,
des monuments gigantesques
se dressent vers |es cieux.
En hommage aux divinités
dont Sapiens se dit le fils.
Les hommes se multiplient,
|es villages se construisent,
les échanges s'intensifient,
des groupes de plus en plus vastes
se constituent.
Bientôt les grandes civilisations
vont voir le jour.
La préhistoire est finie.
Quelle que soit
la couleur de notre peau
ou la forme de nos yeux,
les six milliards d'êtres humains
qui peuplent notre terre aujourd'hui
descendent d'une même famille.
Elle a vécu dans la nuit des temps
et enfantera
des milliers de générations
d'hommes et de femmes jusqu'à nous.
Leurs découvertes éclairent
toujours nos vies.
Tel est le don que nos parents, aussi
lointains soient-ils, nous ont fait.
Grâce a eux, nos enfants
iront peupler d'autres planètes.